on the mound wearing the powder blues
today is lance lin the big righty from
indiana has allowed just one run over 18
and a third innings this season
searching once more for career win 100.
and rendon will be the batter a pair of
base runners here with two outs two and
two two outs two men on lin's pitch
swinging a miss he elevates the fastball
and random unable to catch up so lynn
with a strikeout well the angels today
will be sending to the mound andrew
heaney comes in a 1-0 record 2.35 era
and two with the average below 200
coming into play today
breaking ball hitting the air to right
field chasing goodwin back still moving
back
and on to the track he goes they're not
good with barney adele makes the catch
goodwin is hitting 262 but he's tailed
off like so many of the other angel
hitters he's just won for his last 19.
good when the
400 hitter against him with a walk
and he hits this one out into right
field that's a base hit
and he'll go for two the arm from joey
gallo a good one and they got him easily
wow i cannot believe where was he going
what who do you think was playing right
field
this would be an interesting matchup for
joe adele he's going to see a pitcher
that throws a lot of fastballs
that hit him but it looked like he swung
yeah he swung on it that's going to go
as a swing no he said he did not oh that
wow i'm shocked at that one that's a
swing by the way yeah
original call was hit by pitch from the
home plate umpire
and then it got overruled
and joe madness
he's heated at the moment right now
nobody on one out no score lynn wines
and the pitch string and a miss so after
that wait lynn goes to the cutter he
strikes out adele so the angels need a
two out hit here from rengefo to get on
the scoreboard
3-2
swinging a ball popped up back is short
elvis retreating
chew
coming in and it's chew who settles
underneath it and makes the catch for
the final out of the inning
oh the angels get a couple of hits they
strand one and fail to score and
here's isaiah keiner falefa
got him to fly out of the first inning
he goes after the first pitch and he's
got a gap
that one's to roll for a while russ
snyder can run they'll wave him around
third base
trainer falefa stops at second with the
rbi double and the rangers take the
one-nothing lead
see here's frazier with a chance to add
to the lead one-nothing rangers bottom
to the third
he needs delivery and this is chopped
down to third stopped by random broken
bad grounders
fielded cleanly in the throw to first is
in time the inning is over but the
rangers strike first so here's odor 0
for one
he struck out swinging in the second oh
for his last 18 and this would be a
great spot for rookie to bust through
with an rbi opportunity
castro gives the sign teeny set 3-2
swinging the ball ripped to right field
that's a base hit towards the line
hitting the bag at third is so back he's
being sent home adele's throw is cut off
solace scores standing up and it's an
rbi single for roonetto door to snap an
0 for 18 and to give the rangers a
two-nothing lead so that brings up elvis
andrews
3-2
and that one up the middle that is a
base hit here comes o'dore trout up with
it in shallow center no throw offered
three-nothing rangers the rangers have
met at the corners with two outs for
shinsuchu
0-2 two outs men at the corners mathis
breaks off at first trying to get into a
rundown and mathis just goes straight to
second as heaney immediately turned to
third and paid no mind
to mathis mathis
had the invisibility cloak on the one
two
swinging a ball lined into center field
to base it elvis scores mathis hits the
bag at third he comes home to score and
it's a two-run single for shinsuchu so
the map is stolen base ends up adding an
extra run and the rangers take a five to
nothing lead
at the plate is tommy stella he's
hitting out of the two hole today and
here's the delivery and la stella lifts
one in the air this ball is well hit out
in the right center field and that one
is out of here big fly for tommy
lastella that gets the angels on the
board
first home run of the season for tommy
boyle estella 16 a career high last year
for the all-star
time of the stella all of a sudden right
back in the game with one swing in the
bad 430 foot home run now mike trout
will step up lynn needs one more out to
be eligible for a win he's in line for
his 100th career win 3-1 and trout pops
it up
short center field roogy going back on
it
he takes a shuffle to his left and he
puts it away about 10 yards onto the
outfield grass to end the inning so that
brings up solace his double in the
bottom of the fourth ignited the rally
for texas
a 1-1
zolac drives one in the air to right
field adele back he's at the track now
backpedaling reaches out it's off his
glove and over the wall
holy smokes
like a center in volleyball
he just pushed it right over
and solac will take the home run his
first of the year it's six to two
some of the guys could laugh about it
joe adele probably feels the worst but i
love what trout was doing his smile and
say listen it's not easy to pick the
baseball up here we've seen even trouty
on his some of his routes for your
series it's not easy
the home run from earlier today is
indeed a four base error wow
ryan goodwin would be the next batter
what oh
good off speed pitch
unfortunately for the angels it's an out
they do get a run but you wanted to you
want to do a little rally you know you
want to keep stringing these things
along so here's chu who
singled in a pair of runs as last time
up pay off delivery and he got him
struck him out you thought he had a walk
and so mike trout indeed comes to the
plate as the tying run
six three rangers the pitch swinging a
bouncer to third connor fluff has got it
sets and throws to first in time and
rodriguez gets out of the jam what do
the angels need now from renjifo
a clutch too out here
the 2-2
training and a miss
hurricane gets ran heapho to chase the
fastball outside the zone chris woodward
goes to his bench willie calhoun coming
on to pinch it
down in a little bit at third base whoa
all the way to the backstop here comes
solac the throw
not in time
here is mike trout 1-0 he swings and
pops one up short right field
gallow racing in slows to a jog makes
the catch and the ball game is over
the rangers sweep the angels 7-3 the
final score